yesterday i briefly talked about this on
our live stream
um tucker carlson fox news propagandist
is now increasingly signal boosting
a uh baseless and wild conspiracy
that fbi agents were behind
in terms of planning or even
participants in
the january 6th trump riots and
we're going to look at a couple clips of
this starting with tucker carlson
two days ago listen to him
lay this out let's take a look but
strangely some of the key people who
participated
on january 6th have not been charged
right
look at the documents the government
calls those people unindicted
co-conspirators what does that mean
well it means that in potentially every
single case they were fbi operatives
understand the language there tucker
says it means that
potentially in every single case they
were fbi operatives
this is baseless this is baseless he's
not saying i have any evidence
that fbi operatives planned the january
6 riots or participated in them
we know about the issue of off-duty law
enforcement
participating um in in the riots we know
about the issue
of current and former military being
over-represented in the riots but
tucker is alleging something else i'm
going to be honest i don't think tucker
believes this i think tucker is doing it
because you know he knows his audience
is going to eat it up take a listen to
what else he says
really in the capital on january 6th
right
for example one of those unindicted
co-conspirators is someone government
documents identify only as person two
according to those documents person two
stayed in the same hotel room as a man
called thomas caldwell an
insurrectionist
a man alleged to be a member of the
group the oath keepers
person two also quotes stormed the
barricades at the capitol on january 6th
understand that there are countless
reasons
why in this court document
some other co-conspirators would be
referred to as person two
or person three including that they
are not if you look at person two's
court documents if there are such
documents
the people in this case might be
referred to as person one two three four
whatever
there could be other reasons to maintain
the privacy of those individuals
they may not yet have been charged
because the cases are still being built
but none of that signals any reason to
believe
that they are fbi agents alongside
thomas caldwell yeah
the government's indictments further
indicate that caldwell who by the way is
a 65 year old man
yes dangerous insurrectionist was led to
believe there would be a quote quick
reaction force
also participating on january 6th
that quick reaction force call what was
told would be led by someone called
person three
who had a hotel room and an accomplice
with them now understand that when it's
convenient and they do this all the time
when it's convenient uh tucker and
others will cite
the insurrectionists and not even
question their credibility
but in other times when it's not
convenient they will immediately say
you can't trust these insurrectionist
rioters first of all they're accused of
crime so they'll say anything they can
to get out of trouble
here because tucker is ginning up
another one of these
furious conspiracies for his audience
these
very same uh defendants are completely
trustworthy in what they say
but wait here's the interesting thing
person two
and person three were organizers of the
riot
the government knows who they are but
the government has not
charged them why is that
you know why they were almost certainly
working for the fbi
so fbi remember there is no evidence of
that that he has presented
none you have to know how to listen to
what there is no evidence
we're organizing the attack on the
capitol there's no evidence on january
6th according to government documents
no so now he's being tricky now he's
saying
the individuals we are not naming in the
documents were organizers
but tucker is the one saying they were
fbi agents and tucker is now building on
the first minute of this segment as
evidence for the second minute
and those two are not alone in all
revolver news reported there are quote
upwards of 20
unindicted co-conspirators in the oath
keeper indictments
all playing various roles in the
conspiracy who have not been charged for
virtually the exact same activities and
in some cases
much much more severe activities as
those named alongside them
in the indictments so understand that
first of all revolver news
is a right-wing media outlet of
questionable credibility
number two still no evidence presented
that these are folks
from the fbi so then the next day tucker
doubles down
and actually brings on darren beatty
from revolver news
and again it's this is how you
propagandize
to ignorant people congress because they
oppose the regime
even vladimir putin's not doing that and
there's a former assistant director of
the fbi
calling for it on television and no one
noticed so
we're rounding people up how about
rounding up the fbi operatives that
rioted on january 6.
so now he is without evidence just
assuming
this from his previous segment it's it's
and remember no evidence has been
presented don't identify the guy who
shot ashley babbitt to death
this is crazy and we should resist it
darren beatty heads up revolver news
here we go glad to see him tonight
darren thanks so much
for coming on it sounds like according
to this
i have to say remarkable piece that
you've just put up late last night
in bed at midnight that the fbi
was organizing the riots of january 6th
so to tucker it sounds that way because
of this article
now the guy who wrote the article is
here let's listen
well yes it certainly suggests that
possibility and i'm hearing from
it suggests the possibility
i don't even know that we need to listen
to more it suggests the possibility this
is
all a house of cards with no evidence
people that this is the most important
and the darkest
investigative piece they've seen in
years but the american people the people
who support revolver news are the ones
telling darren beatty that so i
we don't even need to go further and you
you guys if you know me
the fbi is not uniquely good or uniquely
bad
intelligence agencies in the united
states and in other countries
sometimes do things we would call good
and sometimes do things that we call bad
it is not about that it is not about we
now love the fbi we now love the cia
it's this is all based on
nothing tucker's story is based on
darren beatty's story
and darren beatty shows up and says well
there is the suggestion
that it is possible that fbi agents
might have actually been the organizers
of the january 6 riots if you have
evidence i want to see it and bring it
to me and i will be the first to say
look we have evidence of that
no evidence this is now going on
multiple nights on fox news
and not a shred of evidence has actually
been
presented we'll have more on this on the
show instagram page
follow us on instagram at david pakman
show
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
giving my audience 25
off i love documentaries if you love
them you really
have to have curiosity stream the
streaming service
offering thousands of documentaries from
some of the world's
best filmmakers it's like netflix but
just for documentaries
i've been watching it non-stop curiosity
stream has an
app for your tv phone tablet roku
game console i recently watched the
secret lives of sharks
fascinating stuff i've noticed curiosity
stream always has the biggest and newest
documentary titles including
stuff you will not find on other
streaming services they're regularly
adding new documentaries to the lineup
you're not going to run out of good
stuff to watch when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman you'll get unlimited access to
the world's top documentaries
just for my viewers when you use the
promo code pacman
you will get 25 off a subscription which
comes out to only
14.99 per year